mais pour parler de situation économique
nous sommes en ligne avec christian de
boissieu vice président du cercle des
économistes bonjour monsieur de boissieu
merci d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france alors on l'a dit tout à l'heure
les bourses européennes et mondiales en
général en chute notamment ce matin avec
près de 4 4%
que veulent dire tout simplement c'est
chute quotidienne de des bourses mais ça
veut dire d'abord bonjour et ça veut
dire que les perspectives économiques
sont pas bonnes nous sommes clairement
sera scénario de forte récession
au plan mondial et dans la plupart des
pays concernés
moi je pense que la récession en 2020
cette année va être plus forte que celle
que nous avons eue en 2009 après la
faillite de lehman brothers de septembre
2008 à dire que nous servons pas très
bien nous allons parce que nous sommes
dans un film assez dramatique est loin
d'être terminée je répète nous révisons
pratiquement les uns les autres
pas tous les jours mais toutes les
semaines aux perspectives de croissance
vers le bas vers le bas une récession
plus forte et les bourses sur réagissent
mais elle saura peu rationnel quelque
part c'est à dire ils anticipent cette
récession forte
concrètement quelles vont être les
conséquences justement de ces chutes qui
n'en finissent plus écouter les
conséquences c'est que il faut essayer
de sauver ce qu'on peut sauver du
système économique du système productif
alors moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est la
situation de pas mal de pme dans tous
les secteurs pas uniquement dans les
secteurs convoqué l'on pense l'aérien
tourisme hôtels restaurants etc
les secteurs qui sans être directement
sinistrée par le coronavirus yeux tout
le tout le tissu des pme et des
entreprises de taille intermédiaire ce
tissu est menacée je constate
il ya un gonflement des délais de
paiement et même des arriérés de
paiement et donc je pense qu'il faut que
les pouvoirs publics réagissent assez
vite alors ils ont mis beaucoup d'argent
sur la table en france l'a déçu
également a mis beaucoup d'argent sur la
table
cdc serre est-ce que ça va être super
lambin c'est un peu tôt pour le dire
l union européenne a aussi
suspendu les règles de discipline
budgétaire
c'était
une mesure inévitable selon vous abba
souhaitable souhaitable les questions de
vie ou de mort c'est plus important que
les règles budgétaires et donc je trouve
ça normal qu'on s'assied si je peux dire
sur la rd 3 % pour le déficit public sur
la règle des 60 % des gens qui n'est pas
respectée dans la plupart des pays de la
zone euro pour le ratio dette publique
clairement on est dans un scénario
disent que les bois de l'utiliser cette
image d'open bar où l'argent va couler à
flots les liquidités vont couler à flots
venant de la banque centrale européenne
et venant des d'aidé des gouvernements
des états et je pense que c'est la
manière de deux banques de limiter les
dégâts va pas empêcher les dégâts donc
l'important c'est de les contenir de les
limiter pour avoir une récession qui
soit pas trop catastrophique
il ya certains analystes qui parlent
déjà alors c'est peut-être très
pessimiste de d'une dépression qui
serait analogue à celle des années 1930
nous ne sommes pas là heureusement parce
que parce que parce que les banques
centrales font le boulot et puis que les
états également vont laisser filer les
déficits publics ce qui est nécessaire à
court terme
est ce que certaines entreprises
certains grands groupes ne pourrait
jamais se relever de l'épisode qu'on
connaît actuellement
il va y avoir des difficultés moi je
pense qu'il faut que les états soient
pragmatiques qu'ils faut de
renationaliser air france s'il faut que
l'état intervienne dans le capital de
renault pour sauver renault veut dire la
très franchement c'est pas l'idéologie
qui prime
il faut être pragmatique il faut il faut
qu'on arrive à conserver nos fleurons
dans le domaine industriel dans le
domaine bancaire dans tous les domaines
parce que la vie la vie reprendra après
et donc il faut se limiter la casse et
la manière de limiter la casse je répète
on l'empêchera pas la casse nicolas
l'unité fait d'avoir des états qu'ils
soient pragmatiques siphonnaient su
analyser de manière temporaire
un certain nombre de boîtes et bien il
faudra le faire merci beaucoup christian
de boissieu d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france rappelle que vous
êtes vice président du cercle des
économistes merci beaucoup